[Música]
no hay nada más mexicano que la tortilla
digan ustedes este pretende decirnos que
es cubrimos el hilo negro lo que
descubrió el hilo negro pues no
definitivamente no yo creo que esta
frase esta afirmación se reconoce a
nivel nacional e internacional no se
asocian con la tortilla pero esta
ocasión yo estoy aquí para hablarles de
por qué nos inhala más mexicano que la
tortilla pero no solamente eso por
muchos años tal vez medios extranjeros
se han ocupado de meternos la idea los
mexicanos de que están asociados con la
tortilla es algo vergonzoso hoy les
quiero presentar que es exactamente todo
lo contrario
la tortilla ha estado presente desde
milenios en nuestro territorio parte de
centroamérica en nuestra vida cotidiana
en los momentos especiales y los que no
lo son tanto forma parte de nuestra
cotidianidad y me atrevería a decir sin
temor a equivocarme que la mayoría de
nosotros cuando asomaron nuestros
primeros dientes en las encías en
nuestra primera infancia
lo primero que aprendimos a comer fue
una tortilla en sopitas en taquito a
veces un punto política pero al final de
cuentas aprendimos a comer tortilla casi
al mismo tiempo aprendimos a comer
esta fotografía me encanta la tuna hace
algunos años es mi sobrino también
y me encanta por una razón yo hice eso
mismo contra el niño
y mis hermanos también y veo algunas
personas que están moviendo la cabeza y
sé que lo hicieron alguna vez de niños
que tiene su extraordinario forma tanto
parte de nuestra cotidianidad y de
nuestra vida que una tortilla puede ser
también un juguete
y la toque tiene muchos usos es ugt es
una máscara pero también es plato porque
en ellas abrimos comida si o no
la rodilla es cubierto
a poco no les saben igual los frijoles
con el tenedor o con una tortilla así
metida remojada y demás
todos hemos utilizado como cubierto y
también me atrevería a decir que a la
par que aprendimos a utilizar la cuchara
el tenedor y el cuchillo aprendimos a
soplar
eso nos hace mexicanos sino también la
tortilla sean bonito el desuso pero es
servilleta todavía hay mucha gente que
se limpia los dedos y la boca por la
misma tortilla con la que está poniendo
y no es nada más que dos finalmente la
misma calidad está llevando la boca pero
por encima de todo la tortilla ese
alimento es la base de la alimentación
de los mexicanos todavía y su alma
el maíz es la que ha conformado en
nuestra raza a este pueblo que llamamos
méxico
durante la mayor parte de mi carrera
profesional dedicado a la investigación
periodística y de temas de comunicación
sin embargo hace un par de años tuve la
decisión un poquito drástica y que
quiero desarrollar unas mismas grandes
pasiones que es méxico su cultura sus
tradiciones y la mejor manera que
encontré fue estudiando una maestría en
cocinas -méxico estudiar junto a
determinadas
que la verdad entrado
en esta maravilla que son nuestras
cocinas me abrió los ojos a muchas cosas
que yo pensaba que eran lo más normal
del mundo y no lo son por principio de
cuentas no sé cuántos ustedes sepan que
la cocina tradicional mexicana fue la
primera del mundo
en noviembre del 2010 recibí el
nombramiento por parte de la unesco como
patrimonio cultural inmaterial de la
humanidad lo que quiere decir que
nuestras cocinas tradicionales ya no
solamente son nuestras le pertenecen a
toda la humanidad pero los mexicanos
tenemos la responsabilidad y la
obligación de cuidarlas preservar las
documentar las difundirlas
porque ese nombramiento no lo puede
quitar y no lo podrían quitar si ponemos
en riesgo nuestras cocinas tradicionales
y lo más maravilloso en el centro de
esas cocinas tradicionales reconocidas a
nivel internacional está la humilde
molesta tortilla
tan humilde de amor está queráis nos
damos cuenta que es una obra maestra y
ahorita les voy a explicar por qué
durante muchos años se ha tratado de
encontrar el origen del maíz que es el
alma de la tortilla
pero no es hasta el siglo 20 que
comienzan a realizarse estudios más a
profundidad y con un sustento científico
específicamente hubo uno encabezado por
el arqueólogo richard marx nietzsche que
se fue al valle de tehuacán es la imagen
que estamos ustedes viendo la vidente
bocan está en el estado de puebla
comenzó a hacer excavaciones
y tratando de resumir un poco su amplio
estudio lo que puedo encontrar es que
número uno
el maíz no existía en la naturaleza
el maíz fue creado por la mano del
hombre gracias a un proceso de
domesticación
y saben ustedes
en esta zona en el centro sur de méxico
lo que quiere decir en méxico es la cuna
del país
se cree que el maíz proviene de esto que
se llama 'the o simple o una planta muy
parecida que ya se extinguió
como referencia pues es mi mano para que
se encuentra el tamaño de las más horas
qué sucede que los antiguos habitantes
de lo que hoy llamamos méxico
buscaban y recolectaban estas plantas
para comerse sus tallos sin embargo se
dieron cuenta hicieron un gran
descubrimiento que si sacaban del
entorno natural esa planta la pone en
una tierra más cuidada le ponían agua
estaban al pendiente de esa planta la
planta se desarrollaba mejor y por
consecuencia comenzaba a crecer
esa es la cuna de la domesticación del
maíz pero no solamente eso de la
agricultura del continente americano
al haber nacido la agricultura
precisamente y el valle de tehuacán y
áreas vecinas nacen también las grandes
culturas de méxico el mezcla tolteca
teotihuacana maya azteca con el paso de
los años
a eso se lo debemos
efectivamente al cabo de algunas
generaciones esa pequeña mazorca que
ustedes vieron se convierten en la
planta del maíz
y se convierte en la base de la
alimentación de nuestros pueblos
primigenios incluso hasta la llegada de
los españoles que sorprendió que le
llamaban pan de maíz a la tortilla de
hecho que recordar la palabra tortilla
no es la forma como lo llamaban nuestros
antepasados tortillas viene de españa y
se refiere a un una preparación a base
de huevo la forma original y que se
llamaba en agua mineral atlacatl es el
promedio de llamar la tortilla entonces
y me gusta de una manera deliberada
decir que la tortilla está enmarcada en
tres milagros el primero de ellos lo
acabo de mencionar la tortilla nació en
méxico y fue creada por la mano del ser
humano
el siguiente milagro
les decía que gracias a la domesticación
del maíz se logra comenzar la
agricultura en méxico o en lo que hoy
llamamos méxico
si embargo pasaría interesante mucho
ustedes han escuchado la palabra me para
la mayor parte de la gente piensa que la
palabra milpa se refiere al lugar no se
cultiva exclusivamente maíz otros
piensan que la palabra milpa se refiere
a la planta del maíz bueno la noticia es
que ambos conceptos están equivocados
para que sea milpa debe ser un poli
cultivo es decir varias cosas varios
productos que se cultivan en el mismo
pedazo de tierra pero porque es un
milagro porque a nuestros antepasados
tuvieron la enorme sabiduría para darse
cuenta de que si sembraban y cosechaban
varios productos en el mismo pedazo de
tierra tenían más comida pero aparte de
todo estaban contribuyendo al medio
ambiente y es qué maravilla desde
entonces ellos amaban y cuidamos el
medio ambiente
qué sucede
en las milpas se cultivaba lo que se
conoce como la triada mesoamericana de
la alimentación que es maíz frijol y
calabaza lo que ustedes están viendo en
esta la diapositiva
la talla el grado del maíz es una caña
crece hacia arriba el frijol es una
enredadera sin embargo para que sus
vainas de las semillas que nosotros
necesitamos para comer la vaina necesita
colgar por lo tanto debe la enredadera
enredarse en algo se enreda en la caña
del maíz
la caña le sirvió de sostén el frijol
para un pequeño problema la caña de maíz
absorbe muchos nutrientes de la tierra
como nitrógeno lo que la ves gasta para
que el frijol en agradecimiento toma ese
nitrógeno de la atmósfera se lo vuelve a
inyectar la tierra
buenos días pasados ya está bien eso
y para rematar sembraban calabaza que es
una planta rastrea sus hojas cumbre en
el piso cura en el suelo evitando que la
humedad se va por tan fácilmente es una
triada mesoamericana esto es una milpa
eso es un buen cultivo y no nada más eso
alrededor de la milpa sembraban plantas
de olor como el pazo té o también
sembraban chiles por qué porque a
diferencia de los cultivos de hoy en día
en donde los que utilizamos pesticidas
nuestros antepasados no mataban a los
insectos los ausentaban les daban lo que
más les gustaba las plantas del hoy el
chile ahora se ha dejado mismo del
centro yo te pongo tu comida al lado que
maravillaron y otra cosa los herbicidas
que se utilizan hoy en día ellos los
utilizaban o que dejaba que esas plantas
crecieran las llamaron y lyttle y se las
comían hoy son los quelites que también
forman parte de la cocina tradicional
mexicana una enorme sabiduría
tercer milagro
por esto me voy a referir a una
situación que se dio cuando llegan los
españoles a méxico es encontrar por el
maíz se lo llevan al viejo mundo y lo
tienen sembrar y cosechar en otras
latitudes sin embargo se dan cuenta que
allá la gente se lo come se enferma y
está desnutrida y disimulo qué es lo que
pasa con estos mexicanos que no les pasa
lo mismo a partir del siglo 20 se
empiezan a hacer estudios que dan con el
descubrimiento de este tercer milagro
aquí nosotros tenemos la costumbre de
que el maíz lo sometemos a un proceso de
una cocción en una solución alcalina que
es agua y el agente alcalino que puede
ser ceniza o cal a ese proceso lo
llamamos alguien no sabe ni que está mal
y zación y ese proceso existe en este
territorio desde antes de la era
cristiana y lo realizaban nuestros
antepasados que sucede al mixta analizar
ese agente alcalino le quita ciertas
toxinas que tiene la piel del maíz
en forma de microondas le quita y lo
viejo que puede ser indigesto pero
además le aporta nutrientes que no tenía
como calcio potasio y otros minerales y
además activas y otros agentes que tiene
el maíz para contarlo comas con frijoles
absorban mejor les pertenece tiene el
frijol de manera que una tortilla en y
estaba lista y mine está analizado es
más nutritiva que éste como es el maíz
en tu estado natural es el tercer
milagro fue descubierto por los
antepasados hace miles de años aquí en
este territorio
el maíz creado en méxico por manos
humanas la milpa la nixtamalización sin
embargo bueno ahí incluye esto para que
se den cuenta que no es nada fácil como
hacen las tortillas las señoras hace
tiempo dejé sangre sudor y lágrimas en
ese ejercicio de moler en el metate
realidad de cuentas la nixtamalización
también le da al maíz la versatilidad
que requiere para poder hacer tortillas
tamales pozole si demás tienen hambre
nuestra tortilla está amenazada por la
industrialización
aquí les puse lo que es una tortilla de
tortillas de paquete que se venden en
supermercados intento hacer ha jugado
autoservicio
este es un paquete igual al resto de
tareas pero no solamente eso una
tortilla que se precie de serlo tiene un
solo ingrediente se llama maíz
estos dos de sus clubs ustedes pueden
leer en la parte de atrás de una bolsa
de tortillas industrializadas arriba
imagínese está balizado ácido por lo
único goma celulosa o macua ácido
benzoico ácido sórbico ácido fumárico
ácido fosfórico enzimas saborizante
idéntico al natural
los mexicanos no merecemos eso
cuando tenemos a lo mejor la tortilla
más cerca
yo os invito que significamos nuestra
tortilla porque además hay otra amenaza
se llama maíz transgénico que el maestro
escénico ya está aquí lo estamos
poniendo porque méxico no ha sabido ser
autosuficiente en la producción de maíz
y hemos traído que están importando maíz
de otras partes del mundo muchos de ese
maíz es transgénico es lo peor
se pretende sembrar en méjico maíz
transgénico porque eso sería lo peor
porque aquí donde nació en el maíz
podría morir sucede que la semilla de
maestra escénico está diseñada para que
la planta el agricultor de una caña con
mucho maíz pero si ese maestro quiere
sembrar ese maíz que dio tu caña no va a
dar fruto
entonces esas plantas de maíz estéril
también tienen polen que puede volar a
las plantas del maíz natural más de 60
variedades de maíz criollo que existen
en méxico y que están en peligro están
en grave peligro saben por qué porque
las compañías transnacionales ya han
estado allanando el camino haciendo lo
que se llama lobby por el poder
legislativo en este país
para que se modifiquen las leyes y puede
entrar para ser cosechado en méxico el
maestro zen
yo los invito estamos atentos
veamos
escuchemos noticias que salgan al
respecto
en nuestras manos está evitando este
país que fue la cuna del maíz se
convierte también en su tumba muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]